An easier model for rendering is the Pinhole Camera. With a Pinhole camera, you
put a piece of photographic film at one end of a box and poke a hole in the
other end, then you cover up this hole. You do this in the dark so that the film
was not exposed to light. Of course, just about no ones uses film anymore, but
I'll assume you have some idea how camera film works. To take a photo, you point
the camera, open the hole for a short amount of time. Then go back to the dark
room and develop the film. With the Pinhole camera, the light coming in from one
direction is detected by a single location on the flat rectangle of the film.
Put these differing light contributions together, and you get a picture. Most
cameras work the same way. They may have more complex lense systems, but they
gather light in a similar manner with the image projected behind the lense. We
often simplify and think of our eyes as elaborate cameras that send images
directly to our brains. It's better to think about the eye as part of our visual
system, since ultimately it's the brains interpretation of the data that
matters.